when I was 17 and going to Texas Tech
University I had a roommate who had a
book and the book was by hansin Holtz
and when he was out of the house I had a
look at the book thought it was
interesting but it had the number of
footnotes to this guy named ludan misus
which sent me to the
library and then consumed my nights and
my weekends and then weeks and then
months and then as it turns out my
entire
life misus invaded my brain my heart my
spirit my soul everything and I feel
like I've just kind of lived alongside
of him uh for all of my life and the
last three and a half years I've thought
so much about his
life and how it went through these
endless ups and downs and how he
maintained his in def
fatigable
determination to
survive
regardless and I think that's worth
talking
about
tonight
because as Dr Arn so just brilliantly
said from the microphone we are living
in times of
Decline and it's hard it's painful for
us
psychologically and
intellectually to see what's happening
all around us and to know in advance
that this was going to happen if we
follow a certain course that we knew was
wrong and it happened anyway and where
does that leave
us as Citizens as
intellectuals as men and women of spirit
and Truth determined to have some kind
of impact on our
world what does that leave what does
that leave for us and it's impactful on
me especially
because uh of reasons I'll go into but I
had for a very long time been
convinced that we were living in an age
of
endless and infinite progress and
peace because I'm a child of the Cold
War then good things happened in 19 1989
and 1990 and I read a book called the
end of
history and I made the profound error of
believing
it well my friends history did not end
did
it instead we are going around in
circles again with endless
Cycles trading between a tennessy
towards becoming more civilized and
becoming more
barbaric and we are living in times of
growing
barbarism what we do we do with that
information well let's examine the life
of misus if I may and I I have no way
no method for approaching this except
through his life uh because in my view
you cannot separate uh a man's ideas
from the life that he lived the times in
which he lived they shap each other uh
one of the reasons I really admired the
brilliant talk last night with Bruce
Caldwell were you here for it yeah so
you noticed how he embedded uh this book
the road seron which you could have just
tackled as a text oh here's what it says
here's his ideas no he didn't do that he
emod he buried that book in the course
of of Hayek's own intellectual life so
uh so Hayek's biography becomes part of
his uh his his body of ideas this is
really important I think it's important
for every great thinker whether it's Lo
or yeah Marx or or Hume or Hegel for
that matter any of it's wrong to just
study a thinker
abstractly away from the times in which
he lived and the problems that he was
presented in his life well misus was
presented certain problems in his life
and he sought answers um and and and to
understand his work uh requires that you
understand the time
in which he lived the issues that he was
grappling with so here we go right it's
an adventure an adventure to be with
misus in the course of his
life so he was born in 1881 during
What's called the bellac you know they
had it in Europe they had it in US these
were good
times uh liberalism was seemed to be
triumphing all over the world peace
prosperity we knew the solutions to
human flourishing to wealth
creation uh during those years U it's
remarkable to think about it but you
know we went very quickly from
um you know the Industrial Revolution
and 100 years later 150 years later uh
surrounded by newness and invention
everywhere uh so we had Telegraph
quickly became the telephone the
internal combustion was democratized and
cars all over the place we' learned how
to
fly uh indoor heating indoor plumbing uh
was was everywhere uh the uh the
commercialization made a gigantic
difference in the Landscapes of of
cities all over the United States and in
Europe so we we learned how to
transverse huge bodies of water we
didn't know how to do that before we
didn't we didn't have a material light
enough that didn't sink into the ground
and suddenly we got all the beautiful
bridges all all over this country and
and and cities all over the world began
to reach up to the skies because we
could build now with this beautiful new
material called steel that we didn't
previously have access to and it infused
an entire generation of thinkers with a
wild optimism I know what that means I
know what that is right because I felt
it at some point I mean I wrote a book
called It's a Jetson's
world yeah I I thought we were going to
have flying cars instead we got school
closures and church closures and and
Shop mandates right so you know I've
been wrong wrong well that generation
born in the
1880s uh turned out to be wrong
too and it was it was a
Devastation for that generation of what
we would call liberal intellectuals
meaning classically liberal
intellectuals who believed in Freedom
and believed in power to the individual
and and democracy
is is a thing that would work to
restrain government and that was that
whole generation and that's when that's
the world in which mesus was
born
um infused with a a
passion to continue the progress all
over the world wealth growing population
growing beautiful things all around uh
I I think so often of this generation
you know the great thinker Mark Twain I
live down the street from his what what
was his house in in Hartford uh and I
love Mark Twain so much but it's so
funny because you read him and he was
one of these kind of optimistic
intellectuals you like he knew that we'd
live in a a world of of peace and
prosperity he used to rage against uh
the the U uh things like
dueling you know well dueling is not the
best thing but I tell you what a lot
better in World War
I so they didn't know what was coming
they just didn't know and it shattered a
whole
Generation
Um misus was living in Vienna born in
Galia moved to Vienna his family had
been ennobled by the
hapsburgs uh Jewish family a family of
merchants um no consciousness that his
jewishness made him not VI at all there
was just no awareness of this he proudly
called himself Von misus and um and
early in his career he wrote uh so we're
going to go through misus life really
quickly through his Works um so that
maybe something in here stands out to
you and you can read him there's nothing
better than to read mes but his first
book was in 1912 was called the theory
of money and credit and he was taking on
a great problem uh as the economists in
Vienna did at the time they're always
fighting with the Germans it was always
Germany versus Austria and you know this
term Austrian School it it was assigned
as a kind of uh insult by the German
historical school it's like oh the
Austrian School those idiots over there
who are not sufficiently loyal to the
state who uh believe that the job of
economists is to discover la laws of
economics and to lay out universal
theories as Germans we know better than
that the whole job of of an economist is
just to serve the government and
accumulate St statistics and be useful
to the regime that's more or less what
the German historical School the
Austrian School was really began by Carl
merer and misus was I would say like
third in line um there was merer then
there was uh oan Von bumbar um who was
kind of a contemporary older than me
um and misus was studying in this
tradition his first book was called the
theory of money and credit and he laid
out a reputation of of the German State
theory of money the state theory of
money says that this the state invents
money and it must always belong belong
to the state and must always serve the
state misus took a more liberal uh
mangaran view that money is an invention
of the marketplace it obtains its value
through the
marketplace and would be better uh and
society would be better served if the
government never intervened in the
monetary order and he had a particular
affection for the gold
standard but in 1912 when this book came
out in particular he wanted to address
the problem of Central
Banking because it had become rather
fashionable uh in Europe and you recall
that in the United States we uh
ourselves ended up creating the Federal
Reserve in 1913 just a year after this
book came out so misus had a bead on
this problem and he warned the world in
this book and by the way this is a great
book if you ever want to like learn
about money in an institution it's very
patient he walks through the development
of money what it is what its purposes
are uh uh how it comes to be grows out
of barter how it obtains its value and
so on but then he gets to the section on
Central Banking he says look if you
create a central bank there's going to
be a number of things that'll happen one
is it'll always be political pressure
for lower interest
rates and and and that's a problem
now keep in mind he never anticipated
Ben banki right so when he said he said
lower interest states he certainly could
not imagine zero much less zero for 15
years right
but said there'll always be political
pressure industrial and political
pressure for ever lower interest rates
and and he said why is that a problem
because that is a false Market signal
you're lying about the truth about what
the market should bear um in a in a
market economy the uh interest rate
should reflect available savings it it
should reflect the extent to which
society is willing to put off current
consumption for a future uh in for
investment in the future and and and
industrialists and businessmen and
everybody looks to the interest rate as
a signal uh about what to do and how
many resources available if you lower
the interest rate you're basically lying
to people is what high called false
savings and he says why is this problem
well it distorts the production
structure because then you will uh you
will uh entice Capital out of short-term
projects that need funding into longterm
projects and dis massively dis and and
distort the production structure and
create an unsustainable false boom in
some sectors at the expense of other
sectors and that begins the process of
what uh of the trade cycle of the
business cycle so he said business
Cycles will get much worse under Central
Banking so in 1912 he predicted this
pretty amazing then also of course he
said one another result of Central
Banking will be uh the problem of
inflation uh you're going to not fix
inflation but make it much worse U I was
going through the documents of the
origin of the Federal Reserve the other
day asking the question did they
promised that it was going to fix
inflation and indeed they
did uh that was one of the goals of the
Federal Reserve was to uh contain
inflation
I you you've seen the charts I'm sure
you
know all right so that was that was his
first great book and you know the funny
thing about misus is he wasn't
particularly political in those days he
he had that liberal Spirit at most of
the economists at his time but he wasn't
he wasn't rabble Rouser he never
intended to be he just wanted to be a
good scientist that's all he wanted to
do and he that book was greeted with
universal Acclaim really all over the
austr Hungarian Empire and Prussia
everywhere everybody loved that book
good from eus was on his way towards the
mainstream no it wasn't a radical in any
way and then of course war broke
out the war war world World War I the
so-called Great War shattered an entire
gener gener A's belief in the
possibility of progress cuz we went from
peace and prosperity to uh killing
machines uh what Mis is called uh the
first uh people's
War where people were drafted into the
army
and and it wars were no longer just the
business of governments like voler said
you know the wars of Europe would always
go on and the people just completely
ignore them and go on with their lives
and and and the King's armies would
fight each other and nobody really cared
uh world the Great War was terrible
because it involved the whole of the
population and the great project the
first Total War and it it shattered his
his
optimism and not just misuses but every
ones and uh also for misus it introduced
a thing he hadn't really thought about
which is that it turns out uh the
government uh is
terrible I mean he served in the Army I
mean saw it firsthand and it came back
from that experience thinking oh so you
want the government to run everything
I'm telling you it's not going to work
I'm telling you it's not going to
work